if we know stem cells exist in the body
and other tissues besides the blood what
we know is that those cells have
important roles in making the tissue
when we're first forming developing also
in maintaining tissue but we don't think
of them as doing a tremendous amount in
the setting of injury so there are stem
cells in places like the brain they
clearly don't have much ability to
restore function and someone has a
stroke and one of the questions is if
those cells can be identified can be
isolated can be shown to grow and do
lots of different things in the
laboratory why can't we get them to turn
on and be more effective to regenerate
tissue in somebody with an injury like
stroke or like Parkinson's disease and
one of the issues now is to then think
about not necessarily taking the sells
out because they live in a very deep
spot in the brain a place what no one
really wants to go in and biopsy that
may be what we can do is understand how
to turn them on so this idea that we
might be able to develop medicines that
now activate stem cells that we know
exists in many of our tissues is an
ongoing very active aspect of research
so you can imagine that case what we
might be thinking about is not so much
using a cell infusing it putting it in
the place of a damaged tissue but
perhaps just taking medicine something
that we already know a lot about and now
asking those medicines to change the
context to change the signals the
triggers for the stem cell that lives in
a tissue and forcing it to start to
become more active in regenerating
rather than just essentially maintaining
rather than allowing a scar to form
actually getting engaged and starting to
regenerate the tissue now it may not
completely restore function but if unit
had if it had a minor effect it could
have a big impact on people's disability
and level of activity
there are ways in which this technology
could be viewed as something that would
be potentially a threat to the
pharmaceutical industry I think most of
the pharmaceutical industries are
excited about this area there caution
comes more from the concern as to
whether this to know exactly how to
utilize this new biology in a way that
will result in products that can really
make a difference for people and
developing products is of course a very
long sequence of events when we're
dealing with entities that are trying to
forestall for the deterioration or
trying to target particular molecules
that are known to be abnormal in a
particular disorder those are paths that
the pharmaceutical industry has worked
out very well over a long period of time
and are clearly outstanding at doing so
how to use the idea of a regenerative
process that's something that's very
complicated and it's still very much in
the days of early exploration so
understandably pharmaceutical companies
and generally the commercial side of
health care has been in the wings trying
to understand to assess to really think
about how you might be able to actually
lay out a path to move forward to the
clinic I think now there are a couple of
developments in the field where the
pharmaceutical industry has started to
get engaged one of them is this idea
that we can make models of diseases in
the petri dish that of course then
becomes terrific raw material for drug
companies to be able to use it and try
to develop new therapies and we've
clearly seen that large pharmaceutical
industry players are getting actively
involved in that not i think is a real
advantage for them and for the field
this idea of using drugs to regenerate
tissue activating what are the stem
cells within that's an area that they're
just starting to pick up on and I think
that still it's still complicated models
and in general the pharmaceutical
industry doesn't have these complicated
animal models in hell
and so they need to partner with
academic teams that work on those things
and that's starting to happen as well so
I think we're starting to see that what
used to be a purely academic endeavor
and frankly one limited to the number of
academic centers that could get around
some of the limitations that government
funding had in the field is starting to
break and now we're starting to connect
both with other sources of funding in
terms of the academic enterprise but
also bridging the gap into the
commercial world where we're starting to
really think about what are the
applications that might turn to dem cell
biology into stem cell medicine and
that's clearly a critically important
component of the work of the next five